so BBC America's new series intruders
got me thinking about about get out of
me sorry about that everyone the spirit
of William Shatner just invaded my body
again Shatner that happens one more time
I'm involving the authorities BBC
America's new series intruders is about
a secret society whose members can jump
into other people's bodies in order to
cheat death and skirt the law now I
really dig that premise when it's done
right now I'm not talking about quirky
comedies like being John Malkovich
Malkovich Mountain or sophisticated
philosophical enquiries like Freaky
Friday
I like body jumping when it hits the
sweet spot between a crime thriller in
science fiction movies like fallen
source-code
the hidden scanners even ghosts when
it's not being a soppy romance or a
pottery class body jumping movies can be
great but the trope tends to work best
on TV Stargate frequently use this to
great effect cast members invaded by
aliens swapping lines with each other
sharing a body if I am to remain in this
body I must shave my head till you will
not shave my head it's like mental
musical chairs on Smallville bizarro
jumped into pretty much every
character's body at one time or another
setting up the kind of scenarios that
could launch a thousand dirty fanfics
intruders looks promising to me because
it's got good actors and a producer who
did sterling work on the x-files see the
success of the body jumping probe
requires a certain subtlety of
performance and a sophistication of this
scenario the broader you go the more
likely it'll go off the rails worst
offender the original Star Trek series
episode turnabout intruder about an
uppity woman who inhabits Kirk's body
because you know that's the only way a
chick
ever hope to command a starship now the
script single-handedly set gender
relations back by a decade and Shatner's
performance as the woman would be
laughable if it weren't so profoundly
offensive how did you live that down
Shatner how can you sleep at night oh no
it's happening again
fight must fight what's your favorite
body swap sci-fi story have you read the
Takeshi Kovacs novels great stuff which
show had a funnier body swap episode
Futurama or the tick let me know in the
comments and subscribe to the wired
Channel